Obama remember Obama ran as a anti-war
populace to defeat Hillary Clinton right
something Bernie Sanders didn't do in
Two Shots on goal okay he ran anti-war
populace when he came in with he
inherited this financial collapse and
quite frankly did the neoliberal way to
just flood the Zone take the federal
reserve's balance sheet put four
trillion dollars on it flood the zone to
boost up uh assets of real estate and
and stocks and bonds go to negative
interest rates so the little guy gets
screwed they did they debated it the gov
the minutes of the president of the
governors of the of the Federal Reserve
dick Fisher down in Dallas he walked
through how you are doing this bailout
on the backs of working class and middle
class people who have no chance for
Capital formation their savings accounts
their checkings accounts their money
market accounts are going to have
nothing and 10 years from now they're
literally going to have nothing except
what they work for which were taxing at
essentially a 40 rate they're gonna have
nothing